let's talk about this story here from
Newsweek Emily cores has harmed image of
trump Georgia probe former prosecutor
have you guys seen this woman she's uh
she was on the Trump grand jury for
eight months oh my God my ex-wife she's
uh uh giving statements to various news
organizations and she is acting like a
you know those people who go on Tick
Tock and they pretend like it's like a
theater kid yes yes and they talk like
this and they Bounce Around she's going
like well wouldn't it be really crazy if
Donald Trump got indicted and you're
like what's wrong with are you having a
seizure right now she's absolutely a
furry on the weekend let's play some I
want to watch I haven't seen I've seen
pictures
this is going to blow your mind if we
can find it because this this chick is
oh my God my my sleep demon looks just
awful oh my God
oh no how many people was this so long
it's not a short list
now look at her I feel bad for her I
would say that yes okay are these
recognizable names names that people
would know there are certainly names
that you would recognize
I'm not going to speak on exact
indictments
would we be surprised are there
Bombshells of who is I don't think
indictment I don't think that there are
any giant plot twists coming I don't
think that they're any like
Giant
that's not the way I expected this to go
at all I I don't think that's
in store for anyone oh what's wrong it
sounds terrified that if she says the
wrong thing she'll be canceled
probably not
um I wouldn't want to characterize
anyone else's reaction of course see how
she's doing that weird bouncing yes so
that was when we heard a lot in
testimony well she's toying with a felon
probably not it probably wouldn't shop
by talking about it personally want to
hear from the formula I wanted to hear
from the former president honestly I
kind of wanted to subpoena the former
president because I got to swear
everybody in and so I thought it'd be
really cool to get 60 seconds with
President Trump of me looking at him and
being like do you solemnly swear and me
getting to swear him in I just I kind of
just thought that would be an awesome
moment and apparently she had an ice
cream a a like a Looney Tunes pop or
something those are those are really
good by the way you go to the ice cream
man and it's like shaped like Bugs Bunny
or whatever it's got the gumball eyes oh
but uh apparently the D.A I'm hearing
she had like an ice cream party and they
gave her ice cream and then she was
swearing in like Grand jurors while
eating some like Looney Tunes Popsicle
or something
she's got really kid like like very
young Vibes like she's 30. yeah she's
30. and did you see her do the thing
which went like this and did that weird
22 I would have believed 30 years old
that's like this is what's wrong with
our current generation oh that's
horrible now I'll say this what she just
did with all these interviews in this
media circus thing
I don't I don't I mean they'll they
gotta try and indict Trump but that
seriously just destroyed the image of
Prosecuting Donald Trump for anything
and so
people this is what the music article is
basically saying that uh there's a legal
expert saying it has uh it's giving
credence to Trump's claim it's a Witch
Hunt they're saying it's it's not gonna
end the prosecution But ultimately it
will be up to the D.A to decide whether
to move forward charges not the grand
jury the grand jury just basically
refers or recommends or doesn't
so clearly if they do indict Trump there
is now going to be a presumption uh
there's going to be there's going to be
reasonable doubt are these charges
legitimate because the whole premise of
them is this seemingly unwell woman
you know nicely putting it nicely and uh
clearly anti-trump and so the question
is
was this a real grand jury indictment
referral or are they just trying to go
after Trump and they're and they're
they're making it up does anybody don't
know how a woman like that would make it
onto a jury it feels like if she would
have been flagged well I think I think
in a grand jury you don't actually have
any defense so I don't think that
Trump's people were allowed to decide
who was on the grand jury I think if
that's the case that would make a lot of
sense
yeah have you guys you guys remember
this we talked about it before here pull
us up on Reddit what's up with these
tick tocks where people move like
cartoon characters super out of a loop
here to the point where I watch Tick
Tock clips on YouTube and don't have an
account I'm seeing a lot of this one
particular style that seems to be
associated with cosplay and Anime where
people move their bodies and faces in a
specifically animated way I think
Sheamus was talking about this because
uh you learned this in school the 12
points of Animation or something like
that and my understanding was they
intentionally make them like move in a
crazy way because they're not alive and
they're missing tons of depth in their
motion and presence so if they just sat
there and talked like a regular person
you'd be missing all kinds of facial
movements and it's like it's it's bland
so they have them bounce and move their
mouths in weird ways and I think what's
happening is when we were younger most
of the communication we consumed came
from human beings and now what we're
consuming is coming from cartoons and
movies so people like her grow up
watching Disney and Pixar where the
characters talk like this and move
around and shake their heads and go like
that and that's what she picks up and
she begins to identify with that and
behave in that way and then most people
who still don't have that kind of twitch
are watching this going like why why are
you doing that
she's probably the product of a parent
who put her in front of the TV and then
left yeah yeah that's tragedy same thing
with furries too the way I view it it's
Donald Trump should be furious with
Ronald Reagan because Reagan allowed the
insane asylums to be shut down and if he
hadn't then this woman would still be in
there did Reagan allow them to be shut
down or did he actually shut them down I
don't remember I remember I was worse
shut down though at some point barely
alive yeah yeah my parents worked at a
mental institution that's where they met
oh no kidding got married at a mental
institution in a chapel there yeah
that's so romantic false view yeah it
was interesting yeah my dad used to
there's one guy used to chew on the side
of the bed at a like just nervous rage
and you are an eternal will of
interesting stories again take a look at
this video this is this is a very old
video but we've talked about it before
this is like a trend where these people
do this thing and I can understand for
someone like her right she's doing a
performance she's playing It sped up she
recorded it slowly so she can get the
Motions right or whatever and there's a
bunch of these videos where I guess
she's famous for doing this thing where
she makes pixar-like faces
but this is resulting in real young
people doing this weird thing and
behaving in this way up until they're 30
and sitting on grand juries for a former
president that's a responsibility these
lunatics shouldn't have yo but this is
the next Generation it's not it's not
about this one person I have a president
that does that yep that's right
like we are going to
War well hello there friends let me tell
you about why I decided to Nuke China
you're gonna be like why are you why are
you doing that you're freaking me out
he's like well I'm just trying to bring
some levity situation I'm blowing up a
country here
I think that we're going to have a large
Port like we're watching the Decay
happen and I wonder if it has to do with
just very simply we consume media from
two different too many different sources
so humans used to be socially
conditioned by other humans but now that
we have the internet humans are socially
conditioned by Randomness on the
internet chaos algorithms machine
learning nonsense there are some kids
who will watch nothing but like My
Little Pony and then they get older and
they become like brownies or whatever
yeah and then there's people like I
think furries
identify with uh I can't speak for every
single Fury but they dress up like
cartoon animals like Looney Tunes you
know so I imagine when they were little
they were probably put in front of the
TV and their whole social interaction
lack thereof was just watching cartoon
animals anthropomorphized animals so now
that they're older they want to dress
and identify that way video games too
Final Fantasy 10 stuff like that you
play as like a cat man with a tail you
know and it was um uh or nine
was it Jeff younger I think
he was mentioning that uh that's a name
right Jeff younger yeah he was
mentioning that kids also play video
games where they'll play as a female
character or girls who plays a male
character and then start to identify
that as them and things things of that
nature well I think I think a lot of
this actually goes to Pete bootage's
defense and I don't like to defend the
dude but if you have an entire
generation of young people that are
coming up in this world view where the
Algos are messing with their brains and
they're just being raised by movies and
cartoons and stuff and then they're they
have to go make a living and they're
responsible for like vital
infrastructure like I yeah it's kind of
witch someone super chatted this they
said they found her Pinterest and she's
a witch I Googled it she's a witch
incredible yeah her Bonkers Pinterest
account which promotes witchcraft
promoting witchcraft does not make you a
witch practicing witchcraft does does
she practice thank you for clearing that
was a 20. that is that is that is
technically the truth thank you very
much literally the truth oh so is this
like a is this like a an ad for us to
read about how to become a witch we're
going to learn how to become a witch
today she's totally into witchcraft oh
yeah I want to learn one of my foreign
person in the Trump grand jury in
Georgia really putting the witch in
which wow yeah we're in a simulation I'm
sorry you can't I'm sorry we're in a
simulation can you go back up to the
first picture
there's you you you're not going to
convince me this is uh that all of this
is just like random chance that Trump is
like it's a Witch Hunt and then they
actually have a jury for a person who's
a witches to interview and that's who
they chose to interview too we
use and why the you know the colonists
the the Puritans didn't consider them
human they thought they were Savage they
were all paid they were Pagan they
didn't have the the monolith of one God
right of the monotheism thing and so is
paganism inherently evil does paganism
inherently breed chaos destruction blood
magic things like that
um
she's Slytherin she's at her house see
what she's doing with her third show see
what she's doing with her face I see
Christine blasey Ford and Peter struck
did that too yeah it's the cartoon
villain thing yeah it's like
when you watch a cartoon and the villain
goes like their head tilts down and they
look up I have no idea why that gesture
somehow symbolizes villainy but it does
apparently yeah what about tilting your
head forward and looking up is
villainous but we associate that those
those things so when she when these like
these people are doing this do they
think they're the bad guys are they
trying to be the baddies
with the Nazis she that proves it they
strike me as the bad guys but the I was
actually I just remembered where I was
stealing my point from it's uh one of my
Twitter buddies cernovich he he has made
this point like we don't have the the
mental capacity to fill all of these
vitally important jobs moving forward
like we don't we don't have people that
are going to school for it so I really
don't know what we're gonna do yo look
at this that's her
what happened what the heck there's a
video that's going viral where it's a
it's a it's a girl and it's multiple
photos and just a tick tock she posted
and the first one she's thin with long
brown hair and she's wearing like a
uniform with a tie and the next one
she's like smiling in a picture and then
then the last one is her fat with the
sides of her head shaved and a weird
haircut yeah so and she's singing and
then and then a guy just goes what
happened is she so that's what she used
to look like she has like whatever
Jacinda had
which turns into Gollum slowly over time
did he hurt her is that what happened I
think college did bro she was not long
ago College yeah she looks like she aged
down like she looks like she got younger
I mean that could be the Witchcraft that
could be her at 10 or it could be her
today I have no idea I don't know she
looks like she's she looks she looks
like a witch lost some weight got a
little healthier like when I think of
which little that actually actually is
like looks like I mean Slytherin those
are Wizards witches yeah and they're the
Nazis yeah they're they're like the
white supremacists of The Wizarding
World that's right does witchcraft
entail blood magic is that inherent in
witchcraft uh I I do think wasn't there
a scene in the Harry Potter movie where
they sacrifice a chicken and drink its
blood there's something where they yeah
yep kidding I don't know if they
actually did no no no no no there is one
thing where they have to drink something
that's pretty gross I can't remember if
it was blood yeah there's a lot of
witches
I don't think they drink blood putting
animals in a cauldron so there's like
blood involved in their potions drinking
blood is usually Satanism I could be
wrong though the dark Blackness of
Witchcraft like people are saying meth
in order to cast the spell I mean I'm
seeing meth now that you mentioned it
I've been around some methodics and
she's got the characteristics
you know Matt Walsh has convinced me to
be more demeanor to a lot of these
people so I'll look I'll accept that and
I'll say okay fine you know welcome to
the team Tim but uh
I I I I I think drugs might be an actual
answer oh for sure her weird Behavior
I almost think that there's some sort of
um psychosis um the way that she the
mannerisms are kind of like schizoid
almost it's like it's like the Joker
remember in the The Dark Knight when
Harvey Harvey Dent kidnaps the the
schizophrenic guy who tried shooting you
know or whatever and then Batman shows
up and he's like it's a paranoid
schizophrenic from Arkham what are you
gonna learn from him Joker preys on
these people that's the thing you want a
grand jury to indict you want Grand
jurors who will say or do whatever you
tell them to do I bet they gave her the
ice cream and then they were like okay
we're gonna give you ice cream and now
you know she was really she got the
really important job too they gave her
the really she gave her the poor person
can you imagine yeah that's the four
person like they really what the hell's
happening I mean like like if you even
if you were like just a respectable
attorney you'd have to say to yourself
Ninja Turtles sorry guys it was a Ninja
Turtles popsicle yeah I'm Legit jealous
here can we how do we order that can you
order this stuff because like it'll melt
I bet Amazon's got
I hope they're like the the creamy ones
that are like cherry and vanilla and
they have the Gumdrop eyeballs oh yeah I
was thinking about what you just said
about how Matt Walsh has encouraged you
to to be mean to at least Embrace what's
that to bad people to be mean to bad
people I think you can be mean without
being cruel that came up last night
that's why I'm saying be academic about
it it's actually meaner to be academic
about it exactly which is undeniable
it's not emotional yeah no but like you
can make it emotional but you just say
it in a in a verbose way and it's more
insulting to do I learned that from Milo
yeah he's very good at it Milo's
incredible at that yeah I don't know
what's what's happening now Clint to
answer your question why is this
happening I think maybe people are
checked out there's a lot of rich people
that I think are like just trying to
live the life on their boat and be like
I made it I don't want to deal with this
the world's always anyway right
well I think I honestly I think it's so
so daunting many people are just saying
to themselves like I'm going to check
out for my own mental health like I
can't look at this all day I can't
understand all of the problems of the
track that we're on right now like world
war three is a distinct possibility and
we don't really talk about it in the
serious way that we ought to like is it
is imminently possible that we have a
multi-front world war in the coming six
months like that's that could happen
does anybody think that was even a
possibility like yeah they they lied
about it being a possibility under Trump
but this is actually happening and they
have the American people so
psychologically manipulated that they
think that they're the good guys that
they're like yeah we're just gonna rock
with Ukraine we're gonna have inflation
that's running rampant we have all this
Mental Health crisis that we're dealing
with people like this and we're all
we're all on team good because we rock
with Ukraine and we've been told been
told that defending democracy is the
proper thing to do sure Ukraine isn't
actually a democracy it doesn't really
matter it's just narrative that's all it
is and no one pays attention no one
takes it seriously but I get it I
understand why people can't take it
seriously because if they did they'd be
horrified a lot of people are pointing
out it's called the Kubrick stare uh
yeah when you tilt your head down and
look up it's the Kubrick stare thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time